avant retirer de l'argent c'était ça de
longues files d'attentes un passage au
guichet et beaucoup de patience mais en
1968 petite révolution
les français découvrent le premier
distributeur automatique de billets
une innovation importé d'angleterre le
premier automates et inauguré le 2
juillet 1968 au 4 de la rue auber à
paris et il ressemblait à ça inaugurée
ce matin à paris par la société
marseillaise de crédit
voici la première caisse automatique de
distributrices d'argent liquide 24
heures sur 24
y compris le dimanche et les jours
fériés pas encore de carte à puce bien
sûr mais une carte perforée et un code à
six chiffres qui permettent de retirer
une somme fixe 200 francs à paris un peu
plus à celui de marseille qui ouvre
quelques jours plus tard le titulaire
d'un compte présente sa carte magnétique
personnel puis s'identifie par un numéro
codé tous ces renseignements
électroniquement digéré le client va
recevoir en échange un étui contenant
400 francs
la technologie évolue la carte devient
magnétique est de plus en plus de
banques s'équipent de distributeurs en
1971 c'est l'apparition du bancomat dans
les rues une sorte de coffre fort scellé
dans un mur à l'intérieur toute une
machinerie complexe contrôlé par une
cellule photoélectrique assure la
livraison
billets par billet
je t'aime pas ça
ah bon prévient années 80 les banques à
créer un système unique de retrait les
clients peuvent dorénavant utiliser
n'importe quel automates le vôtre et
d'argent avec carte bancaire se
généraliser et genre souhaitent de plus
en plus est servi rapidement le dab est
désormais un objet banal depuis le
milieu des années 2010 les retraits en
liquide ont diminué l'argent liquide
devient moins essentiels à la vie
quotidienne
l'utilisation des automates décline par
mesure d'économie les banques commencent
à réduire leur nombre
le coût d'un retrait le coup est
générateur d'argent est en train de
diminuer
donc il estime que l'opération ne sera
pas rentable
certains estiment désormais que les
banques ne jouent plus leur rôle de
services bancaires
dans certains cas vous avez besoin de
payer en espèces donc parmi les missions
des banques on s'attend à pouvoir
retirer son argent selon un rapport
publié en juillet 2020 par le ministère
de l'économie et la banque de france
le nombre d'automates a baissé de 4,1
pour cent en 2019 soit 2135
distributeurs en moins sur les 50 1316
recensés un phénomène qui touche
davantage les centres urbains
[Musique]